i can count you all the best restaurants
down there
will not be back they're done is it down
like 50
oh no it's down like 90
i'm still here my heart and soul's in
the city my wife's heart and soul is in
the city
everything that the city is doing is
pushing us out of the city what are they
going to do to us if we all just open up
what do you want to tell the politicians
until the city cleans up everything
from homelessness to all the needles on
the street
we're not going to recover when all the
gates are up we're having a party
[Music]
good afternoon guys here in san
francisco
and in today's video we're going to go
to little italy
to meet up with richie azaleno he's a
restaurant owner
his restaurant sotamate the reason being
is
small businesses and especially
restaurants have been
absolutely hammered in the city outdoor
dining shut down december 7th
we're now in uh january 23rd january
23rd
and it's been brutal so we're going to
meet up with richie we're going to pick
his brain on the industry
what's going on in the neighborhood and
just get the inside
scoop of how these restaurants are
[Music]
surviving
here we are little italy colorful place
lively place
actually quite lively now for everything
being shut down outside
uh but guys are hanging out here you can
see all the
restaurant setups that are empty
and richie is in here i believe
yes so tomate i went here once it was
good food
so you can see they had everything set
up outside
until december 7th and they shut all
that down
so let's get a pulse on what exactly is
going on
uh yes ma'am what are you doing this is
the inside of our of our abode sought
the money osteria and seafood restaurant
which was created actually out of the uh
similar to the hometown where my wife
comes from
in italy which is porto san giorgio on
the adriatic shores the town's literally
on the seashore if you come in here and
you're waiting you'll probably get a
glass of wine from me or my wife because
that's what we do
and uh and it's our goal
to serve the best freshest of seafood
you could possibly get
at any given time if it's not fresh i
will not serve it the recipe was
my grandmother's recipe of the chipino
that i will not give out
we have a lot of fun here and it's what
it's all about is to eat well and have
fun our most famous customer is tony
bennett
every time he's in town he comes to eat
here he eats our crab diabolo because
he's a calabrese like me
this is all good in the hood for all of
us i grew up here and
i'll tell you this outside in my clan
chowder
yeah in order to gain the flavors that i
like i have to put in my walking for
three days while it sits and marinates
itself
and then we use it but other than that
everything is cooked to water
you know that is wonderful to hear that
you have such
authenticity with your your food it's
not something that is sitting up in the
freezer
and you just broke i love authenticity
and that's why i came over here first
time i moved out of this neighborhood is
when i went to college
but i came home every sunday to make my
mother do my laundry
sure that's how he went take care good
luck on that
thank you and uh you know when i came
back
we didn't have any hippies in north
beach we didn't have any of that that
was out in the hayton ashbury but we had
the bohemians when i was growing up
before there was any of that
in the 50s into the 60s up on grant
avenue
and in north beach we never had to leave
north beach
if it wasn't a hundred percent it was 98
all italian
and i can walk with you and show you
where they all live joe dimaggio grew up
down at the end of the end of the alley
where i grew up
you're the wine distributor right i am
yes is your name felicia felicia okay
but this is typical san francisco tax
tax tax tax stack
yeah just crash look at all the ceos all
the big companies are all going to
austin texas because they just
they didn't realize that these guys
could just look at them say you know
what
we don't need to be here we're leaving
exactly yeah and i left
so you're seeing this with the wine
industry right you're working with
different restaurants obviously
yeah i just cover so i cover san
francisco just bars and restaurants
okay i do very little retail so it's
definitely
i mean is it down like fifty percent oh
no it's down
like ninety percent peter just look at
this block here do you know when carlos
it's a bustling bar hasn't been open
since uh uh before christmas okay
columbus cafe the same thing not before
christmas
we got bars up on grant avenue how many
there's one two
three that i could count on count four
five
six they haven't been open let alone
what's going on and
all the other areas of the city
restaurants are just
able to do to go we're down 80 to 85
percent
at least we're not making any money here
in these restaurants today we're keeping
some of our employees
going and and hope to meet and make ends
meet if it wasn't for the ppp loan the
original one i probably wouldn't be here
talking to you
something's got to break loose
so what are they telling you guys now
they're saying it's indefinite right
this lockdown
which means who knows we hear everything
something different all the time but i
tell you what
until it happens i can't tell you when
it's going to happen yeah
all i can say is this i don't know why
we can't serve people outside
or inside when i go to the grocery
stores i go to nordstrom's i go
i go to every other place that's open
and it's jammed in there i went to the
farmers market on alum 80 today and you
couldn't move
there this whole neighborhood was
self-contained much like the rest of the
city at that time and you know the
different districts were all
self-contained
now it's not no all that's gone we got
one delicatessen left there's no shrew
makers here
uh there's no clothing shops to speak of
there's a couple but they're
al's attire but nothing for families i
would say
there's no drug stores we had three or
four or five of those
doctors offices dentist offices those
are all gone
a lot of all the little neighborhood
stores you know are gone
amazon the internet has taken over
you know this was a big bank that was an
art shop
uh you know there was little uh
we had it but you can't be open outside
i try how is that you tell me what's the
city telling you right now with
restaurants you have your restaurant
you're doing takeout only obviously
they're allowing us to do takeout and uh
um we'll stay here because this is a
good corner
okay and we'll walk down the next one
but uh
the the city is not telling us much
you know the city's not even telling us
where we can get our shots
for our vaccine they can't get it
together
so you know as far as i'm concerned they
have no data
that shows that we should be closed they
can't come up with any good reason
and they got to get off the political
pedestals and get us it back in
operation
right they're all looking for ways to
tax us now because the city's broke
600 million tax you more tax us more
how if you've been your business your
businesses have been uh decimated how
would they tax you more
look at they they haven't collected
taxes from us for our gross
they charge us for for a gross payroll
tax a pay uh
they our gross receipt tax now we have a
sugar tax that they're holding licenses
up for
we have our business registration our
license registration
uh that we have our health that we have
to make sure every employee
is got health insurance otherwise the
city will find you
we have the highest minimum wage than
anywhere else in the united
states in this city and they won't let
us operate
and they want to take more how much more
can we charge for food
how much more can we charge for a drink
before people just don't come
until the city cleans up everything from
homelessness
to all the needles on the street we're
not going to recover
people think we're going to recover in
six months they're dreamers
five years away before we could be what
we were before the pandemic hit and mike
am i
the way i view it because nothing is on
this nothing's even on the calendar
right so what are we going to do here we
got to survive and they won't let us
survive
hopefully when it when they let us open
up inside outside maybe just
outside that everybody's going to be so
tired of being at home they're going to
come and flood us
and that's what we're looking forward to
uh you know i'd like to be an optimist
but uh you know i've seen too much over
my lifetime never seen anything like
this
and i don't see any plan that's real
that has taken hold
so who do you talk to as a restaurant
owner as a business owner who do you
talk to and say hey what's going on here
when are we going to be able to do x y
and z
or is there anyone you can talk to or
nobody that gives us a concrete answer
okay i could talk to the city
politicians but they don't have an
answer well we're getting there we're
working on it we're thinking about it
over here forensic by night hasn't been
able to open up you got no seats
uh you know we're struggling i would say
this if we don't get a second ppp and
doesn't get funded
i you know new york is losing 70 of
their restaurants and bars because of
this
san francisco's not going to be far
behind i can point out down at
fisherman's wharf
i can count you all the best restaurants
down there will not be
back they're done and we're not far
behind
so all your buddies are saying the same
thing here oh the restaurants
oh my all the ones i talked to are
saying the same the same stuff
the same moan what's going on uh we're
to the you know they're
you know we're all talking about what
the heck what are they going to do to us
if we all just open up
right uh you know they could take our
licenses away abc can take our license
away they can do a lot of things
but they sure look foolish by doing it
yeah to everyone in the city and cut
down the commerce
cut down the economy listen they depend
on
our dime you know they think they keep
saying they care about small businesses
but every time i turn around we get
nailed for something else nail for
something else who pays their pensions
we pay their pension because it's our
tax money that goes into the coffers of
the city and counties
exactly all of us we paid our wages you
know the funny thing is the city and
county of san francisco gave everybody a
three percent raise
in july in the middle of the pandemic
wow
yeah feudal politicians said oh we're
going to give ours back
except next july they're going to get it
all back has the news media really been
out here much or not so much twice
in nine months when we open outside what
do you think oh it's great
we're open inside there we're back okay
can we walk down here is that all right
we'll walk around the block yeah okay
alicia's ought to be ready too then we
have to have a glass of wine right
okay i'm getting parched well richie
unleash this is your moment i'm sorry to
welcome you there we go
this poor restaurant here has been here
since uh
like 78 79 north beach restaurant
been closed since march 15th what's
going to happen here nobody knows
so they may never be back would you
consider this to be the north beach sort
of
the soul of the city or one of the
places that has a really good soul it
always had these like craft businesses
small restaurants local well i always
think that north beach was a
was was the heart of the city okay north
beach fisherman's wharf
you know even when the rest of the
city's quiet we're not
right in the middle of the pandemic when
they let us sit inside outside
we were busier than any other part of
the city how are your employees doing
uh they're struggling all employees are
struggling we're doing our best like we
can to keep them going
we're doing the best we can to rotate
them so everybody makes a few bucks
ah so this this is this is people can
stand and eat in these little
little uh pavilions well these little
parklets that are here
belong to the city okay and if you
notice the ones that don't belong to the
city are roped off
so they got mad at all us if you look
over there you see the yellow
the yellow tape that people are hanging
around and eating in there
okay so this this is city owned
so it's open that's private
and it's roped off right so that works
so the private ones can't be used but
the city's not doing anything to stop
this
how does that feel it feels rotten when
they come around and make us rope up
it doesn't it's not fair in my book what
do you want to tell the politicians
get off your seats get us open it's a
pandemic
it's a it's a disease it's going to go
away
get the vaccines out get us open
you had a spike and all the restaurants
were closed
it was not the restaurants right has
there been any proof that the outdoor
dining
added to this or no i have not seen any
data that shows that
okay and not having outdoor dining
available just drives people to
congregate in their homes right in close
conditions and that's where
it's being spread so what was this alley
like back in the bit in the day
richie like what was going on in these
alleyways there were families here
kids that were 10 12 years old or
younger were playing baseball
catch down in here throwing the football
around on these streets
like italy like someone coming out of
this door someone coming out of this
door everything open
everything was open nothing locked
everybody knew each other
yeah there was one big family all you
heard here you heard all the dialects
the different italians speaking here
all the ladies coming with their
shopping bags they shopped every day
you could smell food coming out of the
windows you could
smell the wine making wow
i can remember smelling the chocolate
from ghirardelli square all the way up
here
so just my little time in your
restaurant seeing the people come in you
seem to know everyone
people you have a good time with it
you're social but how do you keep your
spirits high dory i mean that's one way
obviously
how do you keep them high during this
time uh during these times it's pretty
tough
okay well you got to look forward you
got to buckle up you got to say we're
going to beat this we're going to be
better than
anybody else and uh and we got to be
survivors
right uh the only way we won't survive
if the politicians and and
and the governments don't allow us to
have commerce make a dollar they'll put
us out of business gotcha
and there's a lot of people being put
out of business as we speak in this park
like how much
money did you put into this yeah we got
10 000
over here wow and so there was a table
in each one
table table table table there yeah and
then after we built them then they came
out with specs that don't meet this
don't meet that and
that spec what like too far on the road
or what
oh they come up with their own ideas
there were no guidelines
career guidelines that they gave people
so people would erect these parklets and
then
after they were all put together then
someone would come out and tell them
yeah that they had to change certain
aspects of it
but they were never given a clear
protocol of what was acceptable and what
was not
so what pretty lucky we did a good job
it looks nice
we're pretty much like your sign too oh
yeah the city doesn't but we do
what do they like do they like your food
uh
yeah yeah yeah the same ones will come
in underneath too just
get away remove the business and design
and uh
and just create the food right oh you
know
it it it's a whole where we're 49 square
miles 800 000 people
our budget is is is bigger than most
states
wow what are they doing with it right
over governed too many people get rid of
middle management and start doing what
they're supposed to do
i'm still here my heart and soul is in
the city my wife's heart and soul is in
the city
but you know what everything that the
city is doing is pushing us out of the
city
you know it's not that we want to go
they want us to go
that's how you feel that's how i feel
they you know they want to control
everything i do at the restaurant they
want to control my own house my own
property
they want to tell us about everything
that we can and can't do
you know what that wonder why people are
moving out of the city and i think a lot
of stuff's gonna backfire on them if
they don't watch out
and then and and it it's gonna come to
fruition
i think it's coming that way now because
you lost the biggest conventions we had
here in the city
because people didn't want to deal with
the tenderloin and what's going on down
there the needles in the streets and
the homelessness they just didn't want
to be there
so uh until they clean all that up
how are you gonna get that back and the
thing that
you know i'm confident you're gonna make
it through this richie but the thing
that kills me about north beach and all
these little eclectic restaurants is you
can't create that soul
it's not like you can put someone in
there that's 23 and create that
same environment like it's it's an
organic neighborhood
you know it's it's good look at just
like gino and carlos what's cool about
that bar a little bar there
yeah is uh when i was growing up here
when i was 16 18 21 years old i was
going
in there and uh the three owners that
were two brothers and a close friend
uh and now they're all retired
and their three son each one of their
sons there's three sons in there that
carry on the business
and uh and it's carried on for years and
it's matriculated from different
uh levels of age and uh
you know my age group goes in there once
every month and
where we used to be there every night
the younger groups go in there but it is
a a
bar of san francisco that people all
know all over the place
we haven't created it north beach over
the years the people of north beach the
italian
families the asian families that came in
after them
you know things change and the people
that are back here in the neighborhood
now the people that stayed and didn't go
anywhere
have continued as much of tradition as
they could
within the bounds that are allowed
and able to do do you feel like the
neighborhood's losing its soul
a little bit with the with everything
online
i i think that what's going on online
not not our neighborhood
the city the state the world yeah uh
you know all all small these small
businesses people mom and pop stuff is
they take it they took it away from them
yeah again that's you know look at it
it's another revolution you know we had
the industrial revolution around the
turn of the century in the 1900s this is
the tech
revolution we need to learn to live with
it you know
sometimes change is hard but change is
good we're in a changing world yeah
yeah you know i'm not blind to that i
mean it's the way of the world things
move on
but you think food is one of those
things that stays because everyone loves
good food and technology can't
fix that yet let's say like a technical
technology can't
make it can't replace my chefs there you
go
technology can't replace my management
can't replace my
my my waiters and waitresses and busters
uh although they try to and they want to
they can't they can't technology can't
replace
personality will you ever retire i mean
if the city doesn't put you out
will you ever retire well i don't think
i could ever fully retire i have too
much fun here with my customers
um with people i meet every day
conversations that we get to have
yeah yeah people i get to have a glass
of wine with
it becomes you know you're not only just
a restaurant becomes
your customers become family and family
becomes
uh drinking partners whatever you want
to call it but it's all
as long as we are having fun people are
smiling and
we'll be here
always forward richie thank you
uh for for those of you that don't know
soto
madre seafood restaurant
the best in little italy you're going to
make it through
richie and uh this is going to be packed
hopefully soon hopefully soon
until then until then it's take out i
know that's not your favorite right but
it's
keeps the lights but i tell you what
when all the gates are up we're having a
party
[Laughter]
that's for sure all right thanks richard
all right pete
come on let's go have a glass of wine
all right okay guys well that's the
story with richie old school
italian these guys are uh
these guys are special so it was my
honor to document
and now we're doing a little wine here
even though i don't drink figure that
one out
all right guys until the next video
from san francisco
jessica jessica please play on screen
jessica's right here
[Music]
we get the tag for them
oh i got and i grabbed mine already okay